Jag vill typ aldrig prata om AI för jag hatar att alla pratar om AI hela tiden, men hur långt ifrån är vi att Facebook bara har en knapp där det står koppla in hemsidan här, vi löser allt.
Inte långt ska jag säga.
Make Sweden Stronger Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt en 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju chanobilgenerationen, jag kan inte ta, du vet, vem du är typ.
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har ren dess bra ord.
Ni har inga sura kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig, och det finns inga tulliga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger det.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi Tony Hammarlund till podden Make Sweden Stronger.
Tony driver Myhet-brevet och podden Digital marknadsföring med Tony Hammarlund.
Han har lyckats med kanske den bästa förmågan som finns, och det är att vara ultrakänd inom en liten krets, och inte känd alls för allmänheten.
Vilket gör att man får ultra mycket cred bland de som spelar roll för en själv, men man slipper stanna på stan och prata med folk man inte känner.
Välkommen till podden, Tony, och stämmer beskrivningen.
Först tack för att jag fick podda lätt tillsammans.
Många känner er till mig i branschen, och ingen annan känner till mig.
Du är ju en sån där namedropparperson, alltså när jag pratar med folk och ber dem tips på hur...
Jag kan liksom säga nånting som att ah, fan, vi gör inte på det där sättet.
Då kan folk säga, ja men Tony har sagt, eller Tony har gjort så här.
Jag upplever att ganska mycket av det som vi gör går stick i stäv med det som du gör, och du står någonstans för hur man ska göra.
Är du liksom fasigt?
För det första så tänker jag att det är snarare mina gäster som försöker ge fasigt.
Sen säger jag alltid till mina gäster som jag intervjuer att det här är ingen kurs i vad det än är för ämne vi pratar om.
Utan det här är dina åsikter, hur du ser på saker och ting.
Och jag försöker ofta ställa frågor på det sättet också.
Hur tänker du kring det här?
Vilka är dina bästa råd?
Inte hur ska man göra x?
För det blir väldigt definitivt, och då ska någon företräda en hel bransch på något sätt.
Ja, jag köper dig.
Nu känner ju som sagt många till dig, men alla känner inte till dig.
Kan du bara förklara lite grann vad det är du sysslar med egentligen?
Kan man ha ett nyhetsbrev som ett jobb liksom?
Nyhetsbrevet kan man väl kanske inte ha som jobb i Sverige för en så relativt liten nisch.
Men jag brukar säga att jag är marknadsföra och inånskapare.
Jag har jobbat med marknadsföring och projektledning och inånskapande i 15 år på både bureauar och startups i Göteborg framförallt.
Sen så körde jag över och körde eget för ett par år sedan här.
Då är det podden och nyhetsbrevet som de flesta ser, det jag gör och där jag faktiskt lägger ganska mycket tid på just skapa innehåll för podden, skapa innehåll för nyhetsbrevet och även för min community och för mina sociala kanaler.
Så där lägger jag väldigt mycket jobb på det innehållet.
Men sen så föreläser jag en hel del, håller en hel del workshops och kommer att göra en hel del kring event och liknande framöver.
Men vi kanske kommer in på det mer.
Men är det den ultimata livsstilen?
Jag vet inte, alltså än så är det ju inte extremt lönsamt.
Jag klarar mig alldeles ut med på det men det är en fantastisk livsstil just nu för där vi är, jag och min familj.
Där vi har två små barn.
Jag skulle inte kunna jobba på det sättet som jag gjorde tidigare.
Att jobba på en startup där man åkte in till stan, för jag bor lite utanför Göteborg också.
Åker in till stan tidigt på morgonen och sen så är jag på väg hem vid sju åtta på kvällen.
Det hade inte gått att göra idag kan jag säga.
Du bor ju sjukt off för att vara inom marknadsföring.
Du bor ju, vad är det, Stråvalla typ?
Stråvalla är ju precis orten.
Det är Fridlisås strax utanför Varberg.
Så det är 4,5 mil söder om Göteborg.
Så det är inte fruktansvärt off.
Det är väl bara mer off än vad de flesta antar att jag bor någonstans.
När jag säger vad jag håller på med.
För oss andra som har barn och bor i Göteborgsområdet så skulle man kunna säga att där du bor är dit barnfamiljer flyttar.
Precis.
När man vill ha lugn och ro och leva lite mer svenskt då flyttar man till Frileåsåsa området där.
Det är väl förmodligen en av de orterna som har växt allra mest söder om Göteborg egentligen.
Men hur gör du för att få, detta är ju ändå en bransch där man behöver hålla sig här jour och där man kanske behöver ha kontakt med vissa människor och snacka och diskutera.
Men som sagt du bor ju off, sitter du bara i Teams-möten hela dagen och glöter idéer med folk.
Teams gillar jag inte för det första, men det är väldigt mycket digitala möten självtid.
Dels så gör jag i princip alltid en intervju varje vecka.
Där jag sitter och snackar med någon i två timmar om någonting som de brinner för att göra, som jag vill lära mig mer om.
Sen så har jag ju, den veckan har jag ofta ett införsnack inför nästa intervju som man ska göra dessutom.
Och ibland är det som vi gör här nu då, då gör jag en intervju i någon annans podd eller liknande.
Och sen har jag möten med partners, jag har snackat med min expertpanel kring nysprevet, vad vi ska ta upp där.
Det är diskussioner i communityn och sen försöker jag alltid ha någon, jag kallar det videofika, varje vecka där jag försöker träffa digitalt någon ny person.
Så dels är det väldigt mycket digitalt där, men i stort sett handlar det ju alltid om att hålla mig i ajour.
Och sen är man ju ut på event och föreläser och där man faktiskt träffar folk på riktigt också.
Så jag vet inte, visst är det trevligt hela den här grejen med att kunna snacka med någon på kontoret, men det funkar såsatt väldigt bra den livsstilen just nu.
Jag är bara väldigt fascinerad över hur man har lyckats skapa en livsstil där man kan försörja sig på ett så pass smalt medium.
Detta är ju inte, vad heter de här, Sigge och Kalle eller nåt sådant.
Det är ju inte Sveriges största podd och det är inte...
Utan det är ju en ganska nischad värld.
Vad var det som gjorde att folk började komma till din podd eller prenumerera på ditt niosprev?
Vad är det som sticker ut eller vad är det du gör bra egentligen?
För det första tror jag det var att det fanns extremt lit på svenska när jag startade.
Därför jag startade podden.
Inga ödmjuka grejer i podden tack, utan vad är det du är duktig på liksom?
Jag tror att de som har blivit intervjuade av mig om jag fokuserar på podden först, så tror jag att det är strukturen kring att göra ett poddavsnitt.
Även om jag försöker göra mina poddavsnitt mer som ett samtal, så är det ändå fokus på att lära mig någonting, att hålla mig uppdaterad.
Jag lägger ner, jag tar en 45 minuter, 60 minuter införsnack, inför ett poddavsnitt med personen.
Sammanställer saker, anteckningar, frågor som vi tänker ta upp.
Och sen så gör jag själva poddavsnittet.
Så jag försöker ju vara väldigt strukturerad kring det innehållet jag skapar.
Det är helt enkelt sådant jag är på något sätt.
Och det gör ju också att podden får kanske en annan stil än vad många andra poddar är, som kanske är mer av samtalspoddar.
Vi är ju uppenbart olika personligheter.
Ja men det har vi märkt.
När jag kontaktade dig så sa jag typ, ja men kan inte du vara med i min podd här?
Och så skrev du, ja vi får ta ett försnack om det först och se liksom.
Och jag tänkte, vad fan ska vi prata om på det där försnacket?
Ska vi liksom diskutera familj eller vad är det du vill gå igen?
Sådär, och nu inför att vi satte upp själva avsnittet här så gick du igenom, ja du pratade om en massa ord på min högtalare.
Jag har aldrig varit med om att en gäst bryr sig så mycket om min setup på min sida eller min ljudsetup eller hur jag pratar in i micken, utan det är ofta jag som pratar med gästen om det, utan det är väldigt tydligt att du är lite mer noggrann än vad jag är kanske.
Måste man vara det i din bransch?
Nej absolut inte.
Det tror jag funkar både och.
Det är väl bara att det funkar väldigt bra för mig.
Att jag är kanske inte den som bara kastar ut extremt, om man nu skulle använda sådana trender, ord authentiskt innehållbara, utan jag gillar att arbeta igenom tankar, arbeta igenom innehåll och paketera det på ett schysst sätt.
Jag hade kanske ju kunnat göra det ännu bättre, eller det hade kunnat lyckas ännu bättre om det var mer oslipat.
Men det är inte det jag vill göra.
Nej, man ska köra det man tycker om.
Man ska ju vara stolt över det man producerar.
Så det är för att sammanfatta, det är mycket det det handlar om, att jag kanske försöker slipa på innehåll, oavsett om det gäller podden eller nyhetsberor eller saker jag delar i sociala kanaler.
Att jag försöker göra någonting som jag är stolt över.
Jag har ju en bakgrund som jobbat mycket med innehållskapande, jobbat på contentbyrålättningar.
Det var en anledning till varför jag startade podden från första början.
Jag ville liksom göra någonting som var mitt eget, som jag satte mitt namn på.
För jag skapade massvis med innehåll åt andra företag, men ingenting som stod tånehamnaden på.
Jaha, är du stolt över det du har skapat?
Både ja eller nej, det finns ju galet mycket.
Jag är ju väldigt stolt över att det ska bygga någonting som faktiskt folk lyssnar på.
Sen så är det ju sådana här saker som jag retar mig på.
Just nu är jag ganska trött på min egen webbsida, jag vill uppdatera den ordentligt, men det är bara att det tar tid.
Så det är sådana här saker, det är alltid någonting som man vill slipa en hel helhet på.
Här innan vi spelar in det här avsnittet den här veckan så har jag lagt idag en hel dag på att göra om nyispevsdesignen och upplägget för det till exempel.
Så det finns alltid sådana saker som jag har retat mig på under lång tid.
Som, det här måste vi fixa.
Och webbsidan är väl det som står här näst på tur.
Hur lång tid tog det för att kunna försörja sig på den här egna grejen?
Hur lång tid tog det att bygga upp publiken, och sponsorerna, och samarbetspartners och liknande?
Det var väl egentligen, jag startade podden 2017 hösten där, och alltså första året ett och ett halvt.
Fanns internet då liksom?
Ja det fanns alltså.
Poddappar fanns.
Nej men det var egentligen den här andra vågen, då Per Lerose och Framgångspodden hade startat något år innan dess och hade liksom kommit igång då.
Det fanns ett par poddar som var mer branschpoddar, kring digitalt och marknadsföring och liknande.
Men det fanns ju inte supermycket där.
Så det tog väl ett och ett halvt år där jag testade mycket, för jag har ingen bakgrund från att producera varken podd eller radio eller något liknande.
Så det var egentligen testa, se om saker och ting flyger, om jag har tagit till att göra det.
Så det var väl ett drygt år efter som jag började tänka att om det här kanske faktiskt kan gå.
Och det var väl egentligen att går det att bygga ett personligt varumärke kring en sån här relativt nischat ämne som det är, marknadsföring och framförallt digital marknadsföring i Sverige på svenska.
Men någonstans två, två och ett halvt år, där började jag få förfrågningar allt mer kring att vara partners, liksom går det att sponsra avsnitt och liknande i podden.
Men det är väl de senaste två åren, ett och ett halvt år, som det faktiskt går att köra det på riktigt.
Vad är det?
Det finns ju ganska många människor som har någon sorts dröm att nå ut i brusen.
Alltså det startas ju 800 poddar i veckan liksom.
Och sen om man går in och kollar så har de ju släppt tre avsnitt och sedan har de lagt ner.
Vad är svårigheten i att nå ut i poddformat?
Alltså att nå ut i poddformat, dels är det ju extremt svårt att bygga en podd, för det finns inget naturligt sätt att driva prenumeranter.
Alltså sociala medier är ju inte gjorda idag för att länka ut vilket krävs om du ska länka till ett poddavsnitt.
Och att hålla på att dela klipp, som många gör idag kring poddar, jag tror inte det, det driver inte extremt mycket lysningar enligt de studier som jag har sett, utan det handlar mest om att fortsätta vara relevant.
Så att svårigheten kring podd är just att växa, att få följare, det är väldigt lätt att få följare i social, men att bygga upp någonting som ligger utanför där, det är svårt.
Det saknas liksom ett poddnätverk, och det som driver trafik i sig själv, det är också helt kanske halvt hopplöst att skapa, för jag vet inte hur man ska skapa men jag fattar vad du menar, det är en egen värld på något sätt som inte har en naturlig inkörsport.
Okej, jag har aldrig tänkt på det så, spännande.
Sen är det ju väldigt så här, om du ska lyssna på de flesta poddar, så är det intervjupoddar, många av dem, och även om det inte är intervjupoddar, så är avsnittena i regel 30 till 60 minuter, eller om man pratar Jorogen, så är det tre timmar långa poddavsnitt.
Och det är ändå en ganska stort sak att göra, att faktiskt klicka in och börja lyssna på ett poddavsnitt, snarare än att bara titta på nästa shortform video på 30 sekunder.
Jaha, jag köper det.
När det gäller digital marknadsföring, om vi nu ska komma in på det riktiga ämnet lite grann, så när vi pratade här i Uppsnacket, så för första gången någonsin så hade jag ju ett Uppsnack, så jag känner mig jävligt proffsig nu, men då pratade vi lite grann om att det finns en problematik kring att man kanske inte vill dela sina case eller studier helt öppet, för att man kanske inte vill avslöja exakt vad man har gjort.
Och när man ger råd och när man ger sina tankar, så på något sätt måste man ju snacka beprövade sanningar, för man vill inte ha fel eller framstå som att man har fel eller liknande.
När du inhämtar kunskap, var inhämtar du kunskap och finns det några människor som faktiskt är duktiga på att dela, som inte bara blir floskler?
Det är en svårighet.
Dels så är du inne på något i det här med många byråer och personer delar case-studier och liknande och pratar om olika case, men det är ofta att man pratar väldigt löst om det.
Vi har ökat antalet leads med 400 procent, men vad säger det egentligen?
Och så förklarar man att det har att göra med vad man har gjort med SEO, men inte så mycket mer.
Eller att vi har satsat mer på den här typen av leadgenerer, en annons på Meta eller liknande.
Så det är väl den ena biten.
Jag tycker att case-studier i regel är väldigt svårt, att man får inte ut någonting av det.
Det är mest marknadsföring för en byrå i sig.
Att kunna säga att vi har faktiskt jobbat med det här företaget, och vi gjorde någonting bra.
Sen exakt vad vi gjorde, det kommer du aldrig få veta.
Men när det gäller vad jag gör för att inte ha inhämtat kunskap, dels är det ju rejän inspiration, och till viss del är det också en hel del kunskap.
Så det är ju att lyssna på andra poddar, och sen så är jag en ganska stor konsument av olika YouTube kanaler.
Så det är väl där jag hämtar mycket av det jag tar in, och det som jag tänker vidare på.
För det är oftast där det handlar att man behöver tänka själv, och fördjupa sig inom någonting.
Och sen så när jag väl hittar någonting som jag vill lära mig mer om, det är ofta då jag bokar in en intervju.
Så det är ju egenintresset.
Jag hittar inspiration och fördjupar mig lite i andras innehåll, och sen så bokar jag in en intervju med någon i min egen podd, och så gör jag någonting kring det där jag faktiskt får tänka och jobba ännu mer med det.
Jag kan tycka att det svåraste med kunskap i den här bubblan är att antingen så är det ultra basic, typ, tänk på att göra reklam, eller skriv texter du vill läsa.
Eller så blir det helt åt andra hållet, ja, den här inställningen på sidan 3 i Metas underdokument, har du kollat på den?
Var någonstans letar man när man ska få folk som sitter i min sitt som e-handlare, eller folk som liksom inte har något intresse för den världen egentligen, men ändå behöver vi fatta vad de ska göra när de pratar med sin byrå eller liknande.
Vart ska de vända sig?
Vad är ett bra ställe att lyssna eller läsa?
Det där är skitsvårt, för det är ju det som är svårt.
Hur svår säger din egen podd?
Haha, nej men det är ju ofta såhär att poddar och YouTube-kanaler och annat, det är antingen så är de jättenördiga på ett ämne som du är inne på.
Det går in i det super super nördiga, eller så är man väldigt high-level och det är väldigt lite som ligger där mitt emellan.
Och det är svårt att hitta den balansen för vem ska du targeta som målgrupp där emellan.
Det är väldigt lätt att hitta nybörjare, för de frågar allt efter saker.
Och det är väldigt lätt att hitta nördarna, för de hänger i vissa nördkanaler och nördforum, oavsett om det är digital analys eller om det är SCO eller vad den är, nu och nu pratar vi digital marknadsföring.
Men att hitta den där emellan, det är väl det jag försöker göra någonstans, att göra innehåll som är intressant att lyssna på, som blir lite inspirerande att lyssna på, även om du inte riktigt är där så att du förstår allting.
Att det blir någonstans, om det här vill jag fatta mer om, och är du marknadschef eller marknadsförare innehålls, för det är ju de som jag riktar mig mycket till.
Eller marknadsförandestudenter.
Vad finns det för innehåll som inte bara är, SEO är när du försöker göra det här.
Att bara försöka beskriva ett ämne som vad är SEO, eller vad är paid search eller Google Ads.
Hur kommer man igång med det här?
Utan att hitta det här mellanläget.
Som faktiskt, det är det som man som marknadsförande, när man jobbar med marknadsförande professionellt, det är det man vill ha.
Så det är svårt.
Går det att få en övergripande förståelse för digital marknadsföring?
Det är så extremt brett.
Du säger till exempel SEO eller paid eller liknande, men du har ju också tolv olika kanaler och du har...
Alltså digital marknadsföring är ju bara ett samlingsbegrepp egentligen.
Det är bara för att...
Det finns som att säga det i klan.
Ja eller för många vill ju...
Det är ju ofta sådana här diskussioner om att ska vi inte bara skippa digital i digital marknadsföring?
För att nu är ju allting digitalt ändå.
Och jag är väl av den åsikten om att digital marknadsföring är inte en grej egentligen.
Det är ju egentligen bara ett...
Okej, kan vi försöka enas om vilka typer av kanaler och taktiker och strategier det vi pratar om just nu.
Så det är väl så jag ofta pratar om digital marknadsföring att det är inte en specifik sak att vara bra på digital marknadsföring generellt.
Det är nog extremt svårt.
Det är få som kan vara riktigt vassa i alla fall på allt som digital marknadsföring inbegriper.
Utan man kan möjligtvis vara en duktig strategi inom digital marknadsföring men att vara duktigt taktiskt i alla kanaler det är nog extremt sällsynt.
Då har man inget annat liv.
Hur vet jag som kund att den byr och är duktig?
För fem år sen så tror jag att jag fick tre mejl om dagen med byråer, jag har ju quotation marks här men byråer liksom hörde av sig hej vi kan hjälpa dig med din SEO eller din paid.
Vi kostar såhär mycket bara.
Det var ju ofantliga mängder skräp därute.
Jag tror inte att det finns en enda kollega i branschen som jag har snackat med som inte har blivit blåst av någon byrå någon gång.
Det har ju fruktansvärt dåligt rykte.
Har det blivit bättre?
Och hur vet man vad man ska leta efter?
Hur vidare det har blivit bättre, det har jag svårt att säga.
Jag kan väl bara säga att om jag anlitar en byrå, om jag ska då, nu sitter jag inte på den stolen just nu, jag har inte gjort på ett par antal år.
Men då handlar det ju ofta om att försöka få klarheter i.
Hur skulle de lösa mitt problem?
Och har de jobbat med det för andra liknande bolag?
Och det säger ofta många ja till.
Men man behöver ju hitta något bevis på att det faktiskt är så.
Och sen handlar det ju mycket om, där det ofta brister sedan, det är ju vilket team eller vilka personer är det som kommer att arbeta med det här.
För det är ju lätt att man får prata med seniora personer på en byrå, och när det väl kommer till kreatan så är man inte så viktig kund, man är inte ett så stort namn, så att man får den seniora kompetensen som man egentligen trodde att det var det man köpte.
Utan man får juniora, man får kanske till och med lia praktikanter som sitter och gör ens kampanjer eller liknande.
Och det är väl där man någonstans behöver få klarhet i vem är det som kommer jobba med saker och ting.
Men i det större uppdrag man pratar om, så är det ju traditionella pitchor och man sammanställer ordentliga briefor och liknande för vad det är man vill ha.
Så där finns det ju tydligare förfaranden kring att faktiskt hitta rätt partner.
Ja, men absolut jag köper det.
Men finns det något enkelt eller finns det något sätt att känner av att den här byrån har koll eller den här byrån har inte koll.
Jag är lite ut efter, om jag inte är duktig på att kravspesa eller om jag inte kan läsa igenom en sån här pdf-rapport på hur många procent jag ökat år över år.
Jag vill på ett enkelt sätt se att de snackar sanning.
Men det handlar väl om att vara en bra beställare rent allmänt.
För att försöka hitta, visst det kanske finns röda flaggor man kan leta efter eller liknande.
Men tills syvende och sist handlar det om att vara en bra beställare, oavsett om det handlar om en webbyrå för att bygga om e-handel eller webbsidan, eller om det handlar om att få in en marknadsföringsbyrå som ska göra någonting åt den.
Och hur är man en bra beställare inom digital marknadsföring?
Vad är det man ska pusha på eller vad är det man ska efterfråga?
Eller ska man ta in någon för att va?
Kan man ringa dig och säga, Känna Toni, kan du kravställa mot den här byrån?
Alltså, på riktigt så är det faktiskt någonting som jag har funderat på att försöka vara den, det limmet där mellan på något sätt för att kunna prata på båda språkarna.
För det finns ju, som du är inne på lite här, är du en väldigt litet företag och bara, vi ska göra det här, du ska bara hantera vår Google Ads-konto.
Och vi har 20 000 i budget per månad.
Det behöver bara vara någon du litar något på som du har fått rekommendationer kring.
Där kanske du inte drar igång ett gediget researcharbete och sätter upp brief för den typen av uppdrag.
Men ska du ta in en byrå som ska hantera, om du är en stor e-handlare och du ska hantera alla dina kanaler eller hantera ett Google Ads-konto med budget på ett par miljoner eller åtminstone flera hundratusen i månaden.
Men då har du ju troligtvis, dels har du en tydlig budget som ska följas, tydliga mål som ska uppnås.
Så där finns det ju saker och ting att ta på som ska skrivas in i någon typ av kontrakt också för vad som ska levereras.
Så det är väl oftast däremellan när du inte är pytteliten och det är ett jättenkelt uppdrag.
Och du är inte tillräckligt stor för att du ska dra igång pitchor och få byråer som ska ta en stor del.
Utan det är de här halvstora uppdragen som är det svåra.
Och där går man väl mycket på rekommendationer, få in bra tips på som, inte bara vem man har hört ska vara bra, utan faktiskt vem man har jobbat med.
Och att sedan titta på de här sakerna, prata om vilka mål man har, vilken budget man har, vilka som faktiskt kommer att kunna jobba med det här.
Hur ser teamet ut på byrån?
För vissa byråer så är det ju ett väldigt stort cellteam och ett ganska litet leveransteam.
Så det är väl mycket dom sakerna som man behöver bena ut kring byrån man faktiskt väljer.
Det är relativt vanligt också att man hoppar ganska mycket mellan byråer för att man är lite nöjd och sedan är man inte nöjd och sedan blir man nöjd igen och så håller man på sådär.
Är det en negativ...
Det går väl tillbaka till att många är otydliga också vad det är man faktiskt ska ha levererat.
För är man både överens om det så borde det inte vara lika mycket osämja kring om leveransen var bra eller inte.
Kan man vara så konkret i vad man ska leverera?
Till exempel SEO är ju rätt hopplöst att vara konkret på ett sätt.
Och i paid är det att man ska upprätthålla vissa KPIs.
För det kan ju vara...
Vi har ju haft en lågkonjunktur, det kan vara svårt att upprätthålla en viss tillväxt eller lönsamhet eller liknande.
Hur hård kan man vara mot sin biro?
Om du skulle ha ett eget internt marknadsliv som skulle göra det, hur skulle du sätta målarna mot dem?
Jag hade väl låst in dem i ett rum och så hade jag väl sagt att ni får inte komma ut för den.
Jag tänker väl att om man skulle tänka att man har ett internt team som skulle göra det här, hur skulle man sätta budget och målsättning för dem?
Om vi då tar in någon extern fred och då behöver vi vara ännu tydligare.
För de personerna som man har internt, de kan du ju gå och prata med varje dag.
Men byrund kanske inte kan jag göra på samma sätt.
Men jag gillar det.
Det är en jättebra poäng faktiskt.
Det är helt rätt.
Det tror jag att ganska få människor tänker på det sättet.
Men absolut, en externa byron borde ju vara ännu tydligare.
Det kostar ju några kronor att ta in en byro ofta.
Och framförallt om man så här omsätter typ 3-5 miljoner eller 10 miljoner, då är det ofta dels också en liten uppstartskostnad och sen är det ganska vanligt att man bestalar någon procent.
Men den uppstartskostnaden, eller vad ska man kalla det då, standardarvordet som rullar, det kan vara rätt svårt att täcka som litet bolag.
När ska man börja ta in någon som jobbar med digital marknadsföring externt?
Och hur lönt är det att driva det själv?
Vad är din åsikt kring externt, kring internt, kring hur man ska tänka?
Mycket beror väl på vilka kanaler det är som man ser som är det viktigaste.
Men om man skulle backa ett steg är det väl också hur ser ditt eget team ut?
Har man ett team där man har en marknadsansvarig?
Har man ett marknadsteam?
För man kan ju komma otroligt långt idag med internt kompetens snarare än vad man gjorde för ett par år sedan.
Även om när man kommer upp ett bit i storlek så finns det stora vinster i att ha en extern byrå eller liknande.
Men jag skulle ändå gå tillbaka till vad har man för internt koncentration?
Inventerar, är vi duktiga?
För det händer ju att många som driver e-handel, man har en bakgrund av att man har hackat en hel del SEO själv eller jobbat med Google Ads och liknande.
Så har man en hel del av den typen av kunskapen med sig.
Då kan man komma ganska långt med det och att sedan försöka få in någon som frilansar, någon konsult eller frilansare på det innan man går åt en SEO-byrå på något sätt.
För löpande SEO, där man verkligen behöver SEO-byrå idag skulle jag säga, det är ju när man ska titta på plattformen.
Tekniska SEO är ju otroligt viktigt idag.
Inte minst efter att väldigt många plattformar har blivit sådana komposable e-commerce och headless lösningar och liknande.
Och det ställer ju till rätt mycket saker kring SEO, när det ställer mycket krav kring vad man behöver göra där.
Men jag skulle ändå gå tillbaka till, vad har vi för faktiskt kompetens in house på företaget innan man börjar.
För har du aldrig någon erfarenhet av det och bara är en vd och ett litet team, då behöver du all hjälp du kan få inom de här områdena.
Men har du personer eller du har egen kompetens som har en grunddel där så kan man komma ganska långt för man behöver inte vara i alla kanaler och veva.
Jag vet inte, det är svårt att säga det där.
För alla kriser är olika och för någon är SEO extremt viktigt och för någon annan är det betalda ännu viktigare.
Har man inte det ena eller har man det andra in här och en viss kunskap kring det så kan man komma väldigt långt med det.
Sen är det ju vissa, tittar du på Google Ads, så krävs det att du har en hel del bra koll på tekniken bakom så att du har konverteringsspåning på ett bra sätt, du har all din spåning uppsatt på ett bra sätt, du har consentmode uppsatt på rätt sätt och så vidare.
Sen kan du göra ganska mycket själv med lösningar som Performance Max.
Menans tidigare så var det, visst var teknisk uppsättning en viktig, men det var ganska mycket handhavandet kring kampanjuppsättning och kontotstruktur som var det viktiga.
Men det blir lite mindre och mindre viktigt i många fall.
Medans tekniken för att mata de här AI-lösningarna med rätt data, oavsett om det är Meta eller om det är Google eller liknande, så handlar det om att får man det på plats så kan man göra ganska mycket själv sen.
Inom ekonomi och sånt här så finns det ju typ en revisor som ser till att det är korrekt på något sätt i bakgrunden.
Men när man pratar om sådana här grejer, du pratar consent mode och du, alltså, vad ska man säga, olika spårningar och liknande eller att olika API lida med varandra liksom, men jag har ju hört även ganska bra i Andalade där de har haft byråer som kanske inte ens har haft den lilla delen korrekt uppsatt och så har allting blivit totalt kaos.
Vart finns det någonstans där man kan söka sig för att se, är allt korrekt?
Förstår du vad jag menar?
Alltså man kanske inte vill ha en byrå utan man vill bara ha, kan ni bara se till så att min byrå inte blåser mig eller kan ni bara se att allting är på rätt grej?
Finns det någon sån yrkesroll liksom?
Jag är nöjd med min byrå ska jag säga.
Jag bara tänker att folk är så osäkra.
Om man kollar i forum så är ju väldigt många e-handlare till exempel väldigt osäkra på är detta rätt eller inte rätt.
Den är ju extremt svår att svara på.
Det enda som jag skulle kunna ge dig det är att anlita en teknisk digital analytiker som kan kolla hela setupen kring tracking och spårning.
Det är ju det du kan göra för att få koll på att det här är korrekt men om man anlitar en freelancer eller konsult för att kontrollera att byrån som anlitar gör rätt.
Då kanske man ska backa tillbaka till att faktiskt få en ordentlig genomgång av byrån i sig.
Att allting är korrekt uppsatt att ha det med i hela förfarandet med att ta in en ny byrå.
Att sådana saker är på plats.
För det blir extremt dyr annonsering annars om man pratar Google Ads eller liknande.
Om man inte har all spåning på plats.
Och hur man hanterar datan och att kommer till ens data är rätt uppsatt.
Om man bara pumpar in pengar och krona efter krona.
Jag köper det.
Om vi går tillbaka till dig lite mer.
Får du någonsin skrivkramp eller inspirationstapp?
Skrivkramp vet jag inte om jag får.
Ibland så är det självklart så att man kring podden att jag försöker ändå planera avsnitt en hel del framöver.
Det finns ofta mer avsnitt och mer ämnen som jag skulle vilja ta upp än vad jag egentligen har bandbredd för att hantera.
Jag hinner inte med mig en ett avsnitt varannan vecka i dagsläget.
Då begränsar det mig ganska mycket hur många avsnitt jag hinner med per år.
Om vi pratar om nyhetsbrevet så...
Vi pratar om nyheter, analyserar nyheter, tar upp det som är viktigast där.
Där har jag dessutom hjälp av en expertpanel.
Så det finns liksom inte riktigt möjlighet att få ett skrivprogram för det händer saker hela tiden.
De kommer att leverera till en på något sätt.
Det är väl snarare när man ska skapa eget innehåll för social som man ibland tänker att det är många som gör jävligt intressant och roligt innehåll.
När man bara tittar på vad du gör på LinkedIn till exempel, jag har ju följt dig ett tag, när du har den här bilden och du sitter på en lastpall och så levererar du knowledge bombs efter knowledge bombs.
Då tycker man så här, här sitter jag och skapar videos och podd av snitt som jag lägger ner 25 timmar på.
Skulle jag inte bara göra det här istället?
Så det är väl snarare där att man second-guessar vad man ska göra för typ av innehåll i social för man tittar på vad andra gör.
Vad får du tro att jag inte sitter 25 timmar och filar på mina inläggar?
Det ligger otroligt mycket erfarenhet bakom, men jag tror inte du lägger 25 timmar iallafall.
Nej, jag har intervjuat Camilla Bergman här i podden en gång och hon pratade också om något inlägg jag hade skrivit sånt där.
Men jag funkar ju väldigt mycket så att när jag skriver så är det nästan som att jag glömmer av att jag skriver.
Jag älskar ju att skriva, jag hade kunnat släppa 18 inlägg om dagen men ingen orkar se mig så mycket.
Men jag glömmer ofta av att jag har skrivit och sen glömmer jag vad jag har skrivit om.
Det är bara ett flow för mig.
Så det går ju ofta på typ tre minuter och sen är det klart och så publicerar jag och så vet jag inte.
Och så hoppas jag att någon skrev något dumt.
Men det jag tänkte fråga om när du pratar nyhetsbrev och sånt där och du pratar att hålla sig uppdaterad och liknande att det händer mycket, det är lite samma problematik som vi nämnde där i början.
Att beprövade sanningar på något sätt är ju beprövade sanningar och när du ska skriva nyheter eller saker som händer så blir det ju mycket en chansning.
Du som är lite, jag vet inte, om man pratar sån här språk så är du lite så här blå, du vet du gillar att se vad som funkar eller lite eftertänksam och sånt där.
Hur passar det in i den världen?
Jag har testat ett par olika formater i nyispeget.
Jag gjorde faktiskt en liten förändring här nu, första nyispeget som gick ut för i år, precis idag, i morse.
Att vi skriver, både jag och de andra i panelen, vi skriver analyser av nyheter som varit viktiga tillbaka.
Och det kan vara för en månad sedan, det behöver inte vara det här hände igår.
Men hur det här slår, någonstans vad man har sett för effekt av någonting som hänt inom en uppdatering inom SEO, eller om det är någonting som har skett i Google Analytics, eller i Google Ads och liknande.
Och prata om de sakerna, och sen så har vi ett nyhetsfep med de som vi tycker är de roligaste nyheterna, de mest intressanta, viktigaste nyheterna just nu.
Men där vi kanske inte levererar en hel analys, för det går inte att säga så mycket än om vad en nyhet som kom igår, vad den kommer leda till.
Men att bara ha koll på det, för när det gäller social inte minst, både när vi pratar organiskt och när vi pratar betalt, så gynnas man ju ofta av att vara tidig på poddeln med nya format, oavsett om den som sagt är organiskt eller betalt.
Om det är ett nytt annonsformat, som inte många använder än så länge, men som MET eller Google vill pusha det extra, eller om det då är organiskt, där de helt enkelt vill pusha saker, det här får en fördel i flödet.
Men då är det ju faktiskt viktigt att ha koll på det.
Finns det några sådana just nu?
En sån här sak som kom för Instagram till exempel, det är ju att man kan testa sina reels till en breda målgrupp, innan man skickar ut det till sina följare.
Det är en sån här sak där man kan testa sitt innehåll, på ett intressant sätt, om man jobbar mycket med short form video på Instagram.
Det finns säkert mängder med andra saker som man skulle kunna tänka, men det är partnership ads till exempel, håller meter på mycket med, där man kan väva in kreatörer och influencers i sina kampanjer på ett helt nytt sätt.
Det har funnits ett tag tillbaka, men det är väl inte någonting som har blivit än så länge är super, super stort, men de utvecklar det jättemycket.
Det är väl sådana saker som är att hålla koll på de här och testa det, snarare än att vänta ett halvår, men nu har vi sett i 15 case-studier och 10 experter har skrivit om det, att det här faktiskt är bra, för att då har priserna gått upp och det är fler som kör det, så man kanske inte får samma fördel av det.
Är det lönsamt att vara en sådan som ligger i framkant och håller koll på allting, kontra att inte lägga den energi och kostnaden och bara köra betrövat?
Värka obalansen liksom.
Om du skulle göra det själv, så är det absolut inte lönsamt att göra det för alla olika områden.
Men det är därför jag gör Nyspeer, utan att det är mitt sätt att hålla sig uppdaterad.
Jag tar hjälp av ett gäng riktigt grymma experter för att jag kan inte bevaka allt som händer inom digital analys och inom paid search, inom social och så vidare.
Så jag lyfter med dem i det.
Det är väl därför närmare 6 000 personer har valt att prenumerera på Nyspeer, för att det faktiskt fyller det värdet.
Det är enkelt att ta till sig, det är på svenska, och man får lite tankar och tips och insikter från duktiga experter.
Ni är...
nej, jag är inte sponsrad av Tony, men ni kan gå in på Tony Hammarlunds hemsida på Google och prenumerera och lyssna på podden.
Men i alla fall, det jag tänkte säga, och nu sätter jag dig lite på podcasten, men det har jag gjort med typ hälften av alla frågor jag har sagt här, för det är inte frågan jag har pratat om.
Men vad händer i...
Jag vill typ aldrig prata om AI, för jag hatar att alla pratar om AI hela tiden, men vad händer i framtiden när det är AI-botar som skriver dina inlägg och gör dina reels, och det är andra AI-funktioner som gör att du likar inläggen för att du ska få egna likes tillbaka, och det är till och med AI som för en dialog.
Alltså någonstans kan ju det här balla ur lite grann.
Det är redan vi som hänger en del på LinkedIn, det är redan tydligt att många skriver i AI där, och det är redan många som har inställningar.
Så fort jag varit inne på deras sida så kommer ett medelande som uppenbarligen är inte riktigt skrivet eller vad man ska göra, så har man liksom en diskussion på det sättet.
Vad händer när det där ballar ur, och hur kommer plattformarna behöva bemöta det, eller behöver de bemöta det, för att det är ju bara positivt, det rullar bara in pengar.
Vad ska hända?
Just nu är det väl väldigt mycket testfasen.
Många har, om vi pratar LinkedIn, du pratar att många skriver sina inlägg med AI.
Dels har ju LinkedIn haft och har en sådan funktion själva för att skapa textbaserade inlägg med deras AI.
Och sen så sitter många med Chat-QBT och Gemini och Claude och liknande för att skapa sina inlägg och sina långa berättande stories på LinkedIn lite mer, lite snabbare och enklare med AI.
Jag tror väl att över tid så kommer vi bara se igenom det.
Och det börjar väl många också göra i social att, okej vi börjar tröttna på den typen.
Om någon skriver långa historier med en mening per rad i 1600 tecken, vi kanske inte tycker att det är superintressant att läsa de här inläggarna som börjar med någon enkel hook och sen avslutar de med någon djup insikt som den här personen fick.
Vi ser igenom det någonstans.
Och det är väl det jag tror att vi kommer att hitta vad vi får mest nytta av AI när vi pratar att skapa innehåll.
Tittar man på sådana här för att skapa shortform-video från, för min del, som spelar in podd, så finns ju verktyg som du kan slänga upp en hel video och sen låta den plocka ut bra klipp.
Men alltså tittar man på det, det är lite hit eller miss.
Be man den, ta fram tio stycken så är det två kanske som är bra.
Och frågan om de egentligen är jättebra.
Och lite så här är det ju med många saker.
De här inläggena i text blir inte superbra tycker jag i regel.
Och videorna blir inte superbra, utan vi kommer hitta var vi ska använda det.
Jag använder till exempel när jag gör podd, så är ju där jag får mest nytta av just nu, det är ju dels i lite planeringen av poddavsnitt, och researchet inför dem.
Men sen är det ju i att förbättra ljudet när jag ser till att plocka bort dålig rumsklang, att förstärka saker och ting så att det låter bra i podden.
Och sen att få hjälp lite med att sätta upp ett utkast för hur poddeläget ska se ut.
Men jag gör ju inte allting med AI.
Och jag tror inte att det är någon som i långa loppet kommer att göra det.
Då försvinner någonsin sociala medier ganska snabbt.
Hur tror du att Mike, alltså byråns roll, kommer...
Hur långt ifrån är vi att Facebook bara har en knapp där det står koppla in hemsidan här, vi löser allt?
Inte långt ska jag säga.
Och vad händer då?
Det vi gick tillbaka till är att vi framöver kommer...
Det kommer absolut finnas en viktig roll för byråer och konsulter inom digital marknadsföring, oavsett om vi pratar SEO, paid search eller om vi pratar paid source eller meter och liknande.
Men jag tror där det krävs mest jobb, det är uppsättningen att se till att man har sin spårningssetup och att man samlar in datan på rätt sätt.
För att man som nu var inne på också, kan jag lita på den datan jag ser i mina annonseringsverktyg?
Är det verkligen stämmer det här?
Eller är det Google Analytics och liknande?
Så det arbete tror jag att vi kommer att behöva göra väldigt mycket själva under lång tid.
Men man kan ju komma extremt långt med de här AR-drivna kampanjtyperna, oavsett om vi pratar Google Performance Max eller Metas Advantage Plus, eller om vi pratar TikTok Smart Plus eller Pinterest heter Performance Plus eller något liknande.
Så där kan vi komma extremt långt.
Fortfarande är ju duktiga experter och specialister bättre än att bara förlita sig helt och hållet på de här black box lösningarna.
Men vi kommer ganska långt.
Framförallt om man är i ett mindre företag och man inte kan ta in den här stora byrån som sätter ett team med ett gäng specialister.
Finns det några intressanta case på det där någon byrde har vågat gå upp mot automatiserad kampanjstyrning för att visa att de är bättre.
Det kanske är för läskigt.
Det är nog läskigt i alla fall att prata om det.
Det vill gå tillbaka till det här med att prata om case, prata om vad man faktiskt gör.
För där är väl en liten gråzon just nu mellan brår och företag.
Hur mycket AI använder man?
Hur mycket av de här automatiserade lösningarna använder man?
Sedan har vi andra Martech verktyg som Amanda AI och BrightBid och liknande som kan hantera annonseringar över flera kanaler.
Det finns ju jättemycket där.
Det är väl bara att experimentera och testa om det funkar det här eller inte.
Det blir jobbigt för alla de här.
Jag funderar på vad alla som jobbar på byrå ska börja lägga upp.
Det har redan svämnat över alla som pratar dropshipping och hur man ska bli rik på det på YouTube.
Men det får bli ännu fler som känns som en naturlig förlängning.
Det är väldigt tydligt att de senaste åren har det dragits ner, framförallt under förra året var det väldigt många marknadsförare som fick gå från sina jobb.
Även om det har blivit lite vänt nu så har det inte vänt ordentligt och det har inte rekryterats i den utsträckningen.
Så jag tror att många företag överväger hur många ska man faktiskt vara.
Både när man pratar byråer och när man pratar innehålls.
Och hur mycket tror vi att vi kan få hjälpa varje?
Jag köpte det här, jag tycker det är spännande.
Det är framförallt skönt eftersom vi inte...
Jag behöver inte säga upp någon och det är ju skönt liksom.
Men det måste ju vara en hyggligt läskig bransch att befinna sig i.
Jag tänker att det är samma som folk som jobbar med översättning och folk som jobbar med...
Översättningen har, den branschen har redan körts över, tyvärr.
Ja, exakt men det är det jag menar.
Men hur ser du själv på AI?
Hur mycket jobbar du och ditt typ med olika AI-vaktygor?
Om vi pratar annonsering eller inomskapande.
Jag hatar att prata om mig själv men jag ska dra det lite snabbt eftersom det kanske...
Vad bjuder du in med måste det kunna vara ställa frågor tillbaka.
När det gäller produktion av produkttexter och liknande så använder vi det givetvis jättemycket.
Fördelen för oss är ju att vi, nästan alla våra produkter är under eget varumärke så vi har ganska långa produktspecer.
Och vi kan ofta ge AI, det här är vårt språk, så här skriver vi våra produkttexter för vårt varumärke och här är tolvsidor med spes, få in det på ett snyggt sätt i den säljande texten eller beskrivande texten utan att vara för sälj.
Är du ett plusinformationsboxar på det som är intressant, urval, blablabla.
Så det blir väldigt mänskligt på ett sätt och sparar ju oss ofantligt mycket tid.
För vi lanserar ju x antal produkter i veckan liksom.
Och sen, vi använder ju det såklart när vi redigerar bilder, för det är samma sak där, produktbilder och sådant.
Men det är nästan inte som man kallar det i AI, utan det är bara ett AI-verktyg som används inne i typ Photoshop eller vad som helst.
Men sen använder vi det inte i kundservice och liknande.
Vi har testat en sådan lösning där vi lät en AI gå simultant med oss själva, när vi pratade.
Men den var alldeles för torr och alldeles för opersonlig.
Och vi ger ju ofta råd till kunderna eller så här, drar in sidospår eller är den bänken borde du kanske inte ha?
Den låter för dyr för dig som privasperson.
Testa den här bänken istället tillsammans.
Den tål inte 500 kilo men du är en 45 kilos tjej.
Så att nej, det var inte alls samma nyans där.
Just nu använder vi det men det är framför allt på det här basic sättet.
Och när det gäller annonsering och liknande, vad gör ni där?
Jag jobbar ju med relevance som Carl har ju du med ibland.
Och jag tillhör ju den här typen som gillar att bara lämna över allting till någon annan också för att de löser det.
Så att jag har ingen aning, du får fråga honom.
Jag ska kolla med Carl vad han gör.
Jag är ju världens både hemskaste och bästa kund.
Det är ju att om allting går bra och man fortsätter presterar då kommer jag typ aldrig höra av mig.
Jag behöver inte veta någonting.
Går det inte bra så ringer jag ju två gånger i minuten och är skitjobbig och står antagligen och knackar utanför dörren med hela lagret.
Då åker du för att ha möjliga med bilen.
Tyren, Volkswagen och en sån minibus och så drar jag med mig åtta pers från Vänsterborg.
Jag har jobbat med dem i många år så jag har ingen aning om hur de jobbar.
Ring inte, alla som lyssnar på den och är i Microsoft, ring mig inte, jag vill inte ha några DMs, ni behöver inte säga att jag ska benchmarka.
Ja, vi har gjort det, sluta nu, det räcker.
Det är kul att höra hur man anammar det, för det blir lätt att hänger man på LinkedIn eller hänger i andra sociala kanaler, så känns det som att man ligger extremt långt efter som bolag om man inte gör allt med AI och just nu sitter och jobbar och bygger agenter för allt från kundtjänst till marknadsföring.
Det är klart vi testar men vi går inte all in på någonting, utan vi försöker mer hålla oss.
Mina kollegor är väldigt mycket mer tekniskt intresserade än vad jag är.
Så de gör ju allt de kan för att förinkla livet.
Och det är bara positivt.
Får jag gå tillbaka till dig nu?
Är det okej att jag återtar kontrollen över min boll?
Ja du får ställa frågor nu.
Ja tacka, vad schysst.
Du har pratat lite grann om att du vill hålla lite event och liknande.
Och vi har pratat om att inte hålla kurser när du och jag pratade inför detta.
Kan du inte prata lite om vart bolaget är på väg och var du...
Du nämnde också att du inte hade tid att göra mer än ett poddavsnitt i varannan vecka, så hur ska du kunna hålla ett event?
Bara snacka lite framtid.
Det går vi tillbaka till, förra året så fick vi vårt andra barn.
Vi har också en son på sex år nu, som fyller sju här i år.
Så det här året känner jag väl att, okej men nu har vi väl lite landat i att vi har två barn.
Jag kan ta på mig vissa saker mer än vi har gjort historiskt sett.
Och en sådan sak som jag har velat göra under hur lång tid som helst, och många har frågat efter, det är ju just event.
Jag saknar själv, du sitter i Mölleleka, jag sitter söderom Göteborg i Stråvalla.
Här på västkusten finns det exakt nada när det gäller marknadsföring.
Det finns ingenting över huvud taget.
Det närmaste skulle jag säga, det finns väl några mindre meetups, självklart i några grupper.
Och sen finns det där marknadschefen och liknande som träffas ibland.
Men det finns ingen marknadsförening för den gick i konkurs i pandemin.
Och det närmaste marknadsförening, eller det roligaste eventet egentligen som kommer hit det är Congress.
Men det är ju e-handel och en stor konferens och jag skulle nästan säga det är nästan mer mässa och samlingsplats än något event.
Så det är väl grunden i det varför jag vill göra eventet.
Jag ser att det behövs, jag vill ha det själv.
Och vi var inne på det tidigare, jag sitter i Stråvalla söder om Göteborg.
Det är ett perfekt sätt för mig att istället för att träffa människor varje dag fysiskt så kan jag en gång i kvartalet eller en gång i halvåret så sätter jag upp ett event i Göteborg och så sätter jag upp ett event i Stockholm andra halvåret.
Det är väl någonstans där det grundar i.
När börjar dina event?
Jag har faktiskt möte med en partner i nästa vecka och det är väl en grund i att jag faktiskt ska kunna göra det.
Det är att jag behöver kunna fokusera på innehållet i eventet, inte att producera själva eventet i sig.
För det är väl där bandbredden återigen kommer in.
Jag vill inte bygga ett stort team, utan jag vill sätta ihop ett team bara för eventen.
Och där vill jag kunna fokusera på att driva eventet, vara moderator, hänga med gästerna, kanske köra lite fireside chats och paneler på scen, men inte hålla koll på att anmälningssystemet funkar och att betalningen funkar och allt det där runtomkring.
Utan där vill jag ha med mig partners, så det är väl det som jag håller på att se ihop innan jag kan speaka ett datum för det egentligen.
Är du en RMI-gitt, vill du inte ha några kollegor?
Jag tycker att jag har kollegor, det är ju många som jobbar helt remote, men man måste ju inte ha kollegor som man sitter rygg mot rygg med på något sätt tycker jag.
Jag tycker att jag får tillräckligt mycket social stimulans i det digitala eller hybrida sättet, och så träffar jag folk på event och föreläsningar och liknande, så jag tänker inte att det är...
Jag är inte alltför mycket RMI-t i alla fall.
Men pratar vi om det här, varför jag inte vill ha kurser som du var inne på, det är ju egentligen för det så tror jag mer på event framöver, det är det vi behöver just nu, inte minst inom min bransch, att det finns ett par exempel på bra community-event och sådär, som det är det man vill ha.
Alltså en till kurs i SEO eller vad det än må vara, det är inte det som man är ut efter, utan man är ut efter att få snacka om intressanta saker tillsammans med liknande människor.
Och det här är en bransch, det finns ganska lite av det skulle jag säga.
Trots att det inte borde vara så, jag menar inom e-handel, hur man är, hur många event och konferenser finns det där?
Jag tror du mjutar dig själv nu.
Nej jag tror inte, jag har bara inte full koll på hur många event vi har inom e-handel, men jag ska googla och skicka en sammanställning sen.
Ja men det är ju lätt 10-15 olika, ordentliga e-handelsevent och meetups.
Allt från stora som The Congress till Success Abroad och The Next.
Det finns mängder med olika e-handelsevent.
För SAS finns det också en hel del, och sen görs en hel del för CMOs, en målgrupp som har extremt lite tid och jag tycker att det saknas det här för de som faktiskt jobbar med marknadsföring taktiskt.
Det är väl det som jag vill skapa.
Och jag menar detta på ett kärleksfullt sätt, jag säger alltid så innan jag ska ställa en drygfråga.
Men varför, min känsla när man går på event, jag har varit på ett gäng sådär, de är ju ofta precis skittråkiga.
Det blir liksom fruktansvärt slätstryket och folk drar stories som är såhär, aha, ja ja, vad ska jag göra med den här informationen?
Typ, vad är det?
Hur ska du kunna utforma ett event här som blir intressant?
Jag hade gärna gått på det här eventet.
Men återigen finns det ju en svårighet i att folk inte kommer vilja öppna upp sig ordentligt eller att det kanske kommer en ny uppdatering eller grej för två veckor sedan och det har man inte förberett för inför eventet.
Det är ju en ganska svår genre att hålla ett event inom.
För det första, ja det är en svår genre men jag tror mycket går tillbaka till att bjuda in rätt typ av människor.
Att det är de här personerna som faktiskt vågar så prata.
För alla experter och specialister vågar inte ställa sig och ha åsikter.
Men det finns ju ett gäng med personer som faktiskt vågar säga saker och vad de tycker och att det här står jag för att jag tycker på det här sättet.
Så det här har vi gjort.
Utan att man för den takens skull skulle släppa hela sin strategi för någonting under ett event.
Men det finns ju någonstans ett mellanting mellan att säga att vi ökade antalet leads med 400 procent och att alternativt då lägga ut hela planen för vad man har gjort.
Det måste ju finnas någonting däremellan där man kan ge väldigt mycket bra insikter och inspirera på ett sätt som jag tycker att man generellt sätter på de flesta event där det är lite föreläsning och lite paneler där man kanske inte vågar göra det.
Jag tänker att det är min uppgift att hitta rätt personer till det.
Och jag kommer kräva att man ska göra det om man ska vara med.
Det låter bra.
Har du något exempel på sådana här personer som du tycker är väldigt bra på att stå för någonting?
Alltså ett namn som dyker upp direkt i mitt huvud det är Fedja Porovic.
För det första har han väldigt mycket åsikter, men han har inte bara åsikter utan han kan faktiskt backa upp det med att han gjort en hel del, han har växt ett antal bolag med sin plan, med sina strategier på ett riktigt inspirerande sätt och han pratar om det på olika ställen.
Jag har haft med han i podden ett par gånger och han är inte rädd heller för att dela vad han tycker och tänker eller hur de har gjort saker och ting.
Så det är väl en sån person.
När vi pratar SEO'er så är det Pontus V.
Pelius är jätteduktig på att dela med sig av tankar och insikter.
Ulrika Vibari har jag haft med i podden ett gäng med gånger.
Jag skulle egentligen kunna säga att många av de som varit med i poddflödet, ska ju inte titta på poddflödet, så skulle man kunna hitta ett gäng av de människorna där som är riktigt, som vågar prata och vågar stå för saker och ting.
Man får gå igenom din vännerlista på LinkedIn.
Så får man leta där.
Alla de är expertpanel, det är ju det vi gör varje vecka.
Vi förklarar någonting vad någonting betyder och varför vi tycker att någonting är viktigt.
Nu är det väldigt i litet format men det är ändå någonting som jag försöker hitta den typen av personer.
Som sista fråga skulle jag vilja ha i en värld då som kanske automatiseras, eller om man vill säga demokratiseras, som folk säger ibland.
Hur gör man som marknadsförare eller om man har ett intresse för att förstå den här världen?
Vad ska man fokusera på för att kunna behålla sin edge eller för att kunna vara lite bättre än de andra?
För det första så tror jag fortfarande extremt mycket på att man ska ha någon typ av T-formad kompetens.
Man måste förstå marknadsföring bredare om man ska vara duktig inom åtminstone ett par olika områden inom marknadsföring för att bara vara duktig på SCO, inte ha koll på marknadsföring generellt sett.
Då blir man en duktig specialist.
Men man blir också det här, har man bara en hammare så ser allt ut som en spik.
Så jag tror ändå att det fortsatt gäller det här med att ha en T-formad expertis, att man har förstå marknadsföring i grunden.
Och sen hittar man de här områdena, inte bara ett, utan gärna ett par stycken som är mer närbesläktade, där man kan se synergier och där man fokuserar lite extra.
För jag tror samtidigt att det är farligt just nu att bara fokusera på en enda kanal.
Jag menar de som var TikTok-specialister i helgen och just nu kanske funderar lite extra, eller TikTok-kreatör.
Men om du har ett par närbesläktade ämnen, då kommer du nog vara vass framöver också.
Sen så handlar det mycket om hela tiden att hitta några källor för att hämta inspiration och vad man ska testa härnäst.
Och hämta kunskap och sen implementera det.
Alltså testa.
Det finns nog inget bättre sätt skulle jag säga än att faktiskt bara göra det på sätt.
För utan det här system att faktiskt göra någonting, då blir den kunskapen helt...
Den sätter sig för det första inte.
Och det blir ingenting som man kan få användning för över huvud taget.
Det är väl någonting som är viktigt.
Sen tror jag att det som man behöver lägga till där är att vi faktiskt måste lära oss hur vi, inom de här specialistområdena, hur kan vi använda AI för att någonstans förstärka oss själva.
Inte ersätta oss själva just nu än så länge, men bli väldigt mycket bättre.
För det är som sagt, tittar man på LinkedIn så ser alla ut som att de är super avancerade och de använder chat-qbta precis allting.
Men när man pratar med många så är de inte riktigt så avancerade som de ger sken av.
Men kan man vara där, man kan hålla sig i framkant genom att specialisera sig på några ämnen och försöka hämta och lära sig nytt inom dem hela tiden.
Och sedan faktiskt fokusera på hur kan man använda AI till olika delar inom de sakerna.
Då kommer man förhoppningsvis att ha ett jobb ett bra tag framöver.
Egentligen skaffa en bra kund som är öppen för att du vågar testa lite grann och pusha det och se vad du lär dig.
En bra kund, eller många av de duktigaste SEO-erna, hur många sidoprojekt har de för att testa olika taktiker, hur olika typer av innehåll slår osv.
Det gäller oavsett om du jobbar med SEO, om du jobbar med videoskapande för marknadsföringar, om du jobbar med meta-annonsiering eller Google Ads.
Du kanske inte testar det på din största kund, det kanske inte alltid uppskattas.
Men man behöver ju hitta de här, antingen ett eget sidoprojekt där man faktiskt kan testa det i liten skala, eller att bara ha skojprojekt.
Ja, jag köper det.
Toni, tack så jättemycket för att du var med.
Jag känner mig redan mer professionell och ska ta tag i mitt liv här.
Det är jättebra, vi får ta och snacka någon gång, jag får komma upp till Mölleke och så får vi snacka lite mer.
Det är så vi gör.
Ha det jättebra!
Jag tillöjer den här typen som gillar att bara lämna över allting till någon annan också för de löser det så att jag har ingen aning, du får fråga honom.